well it looks like Spider-Man fans and
Venom fans are finally going to be
getting what we've been hoping and
waiting for and that is a crossover of
not only Tom Hardy's Venom and Tom
Holland Spider-Man but a crossover with
the MCU and Sony's spider-verse yes it
does indeed seem like that is the plan
for both Marvel and Sony with Sony
basically having a huge grand plan of
doing a movie mie so big that it will be
the Avengers endgame of the Sony
Spider-Man universe except it's going to
be more like Avengers Secret Wars with
the exception that instead of having
multiple different superheroes come from
all of these different universes they're
pretty much just going to be Spider-Man
Spider-Man variants and other Spider-Man
iterations this is looking more and more
like our future from Marvel and Sony now
Sony just released the trailer for
Madame web a couple of days ago and
Venom 3 is supposed to to come out
November 8th of
2024 they still have filming to do
however they just picked it up since the
strikes are over so as far as we know
that is the date and what we've heard so
far from some insiders is that we are
expected to see Tom Hardy's Venom and
Tom Holland's Spider-Man face off
against each other sooner rather than
later so right now all eyes are pointed
at Venom 3 but we do have some news
today about Spider-Man 4 with Tom
Holland plus like I mentioned Sony's
overall combined with Marvel Studios for
the future of the Sony spiderverse and
Tom Holland Spider-Man we'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest Spider-Man news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment down below
you are automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
gets to pick one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month so
before the strike started Marvel came
out Sony came out even Tom Holland came
out and talked aled about how they had
already started working on Spider-Man 4
they were meeting at the studio they
were going over the script and Tom
Holland said that he really liked the
script so things have been in motion for
a while the strikes obviously delayed
the movie and postponed them talking
about it and further developing it but
now they're back on it and Marvel is
moving full steam ahead the strikes
delayed them but now they are working on
a lot and they delayed a lot the
Thunderbolts blade Captain America Brave
New World the only movie coming out next
year in 2024 is Deadpool 3 and why well
because they are now working on all of
this since they finally can since the
strikes of over and of course in the
midst of working on all of their
projects Spider-Man 4 is one of those
projects and we heard today from Insider
Daniel rpk that Spider-Man 4 is going to
be kind of a little bit of a Multiverse
film just like Spider-Man 3 no way home
was however much like Spider-Man no way
home Spider-Man 4 will be a Sony
Spider-Man universe connection so the
Spider-Man Multiverse not the Multiverse
as a whole in the MCU he posted on his
patreon that in Marvel Studios
Spider-Man 4 there will be more
connections to the SSU Sony Spider-Man
universe Paving the way for a potential
merger of the MCU and SSU and this is
huge ever since Spider-Man No Way H home
came out and Sony announced that they
were doing Madame Webb craving the
Hunter and other Spider-Man movies we've
pretty much theorized that Sony is going
to lead up to a big Crossover with all
of their characters that they are
creating in this universe which is of
course a shared universe and that they
were most likely moving towards
Spider-Man spider gedon which is just
even insane to think about but now it
sounds more and more like this is the
end game for Sony they are indeed
building up to something just like the
beginning of the MCU led to the Avengers
and of course the entire Infinity Saga
led up to Avengers Infinity war and
endgame that's what Sony is planning on
doing theyve seen it work for Marvel
they have realized that Spider-Man is a
cash cow for them and is a massive
success pretty much all around every
time speaking of Tom Holland Spider-Man
that is so of course why would they not
want to have the universe that they are
creating eventually have Tom Holland in
it and the good news is we don't have to
wait till spider gon to see him he is
most likely coming in venom 3 or Venom
is most likely arriving in the MCU in
Spider-Man 4 on October 24th The Insider
my time to shine hello said this in a
tweet responding to another tweet of
which Venom was better Spider-Man PS5 or
Sony Spider-Man universe and she said
the movies did it better they didn't
even touch on the split personality
stuff in the game movie Venom is also so
much fun I can't wait to see him and Tom
Holland Spidey fight sooner than you
think and of course like we have been
talking about for a while Tom Hardy has
been teasing a Spider-Man vers Venom
fight for a while now we all know what
Tom Hardy does he posts a picture on his
Instagram of Venom and Spider-Man or
just of Spider-Man and then deletes it
right away but he knows we take
screenshots so does this on purpose then
in an interview he said outright the end
goal for Venom is Venom vers Spider-Man
if this is the Olympics then Spider-Man
is the gold medal and that they would be
crazy not to do that so it looks like
Tom Holland Spider-Man might be in venom
3 since this is supposed to be the last
Venom film that Tom Hardy is doing and
if he wants to go out with the bang well
him versus Spider-Man is arguably the
best way to go out and we would be
getting that next year Spider-Man 4 is
supposed to come out between Avengers
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
now with everything being delayed and
pushed back we don't really know when
we're going to get Avengers Secret Wars
it could get pushed back again and some
people have estimated that we might not
even get it till 2028 so Insider my time
to shine Hello's tweet stating it's
going to happen sooner than you think is
probably referring to Venom 3 which
would in turn set up Spider-Man 4 to
deal more with the Multiverse of the SSU
Sony Spider-Man universe so from here
it's all about building building up a
universe and preparing fans for a
crossover something that is also worth
noting that's very interesting is
something that was revealed in the book
MCU the reign of Marvel Studios and that
is the fact that Chris McKenna and Eric
sumers the writers for Spider-Man no way
home were told that Craven the hunter
was unavailable until Sony established
him in a Solo movie which is really
interesting because this means that they
can eventually have him in the MCU but
they need him to be in the SSU first
which means a crossover could happen it
seems like this was always part of
Sony's plan Amy Pascal did say that they
of course would be foolish to not build
up to a Sinister 6 eventually but that
is most likely going to happen in the
MCU what is most likely going to happen
in the Sony Spider-Man universe is they
do a spider gedon story a story in which
a ton of different Spider-Man variants
from a bunch of different universes and
iterations coming from different
universes all come to one universe and
when I say a bunch I mean a bunch just
to name a handful in the comics they had
Spider-Man of course Peter Parker
Superior octopus or superior Spider-Man
Scarlet Spider Ben Riley Scarlet Spider
Kane Parker silk spider Spider
Girl both spider girls Ana and may they
even had Spider-Man from the PS4 game
come into the comics universe and this
is what we've been theorizing is going
to happen in the Sony Spider-Man
universe and now insiders are teasing it
plus Sony is kind kind of teasing it
thems if we take a look at the Madame
web trailer we see a bunch of different
Spider-Man iterations we have Julia
Carpenter as Spiderwoman we have Maddie
Franklin Spiderwoman and we have Ana as
Spider Girl and if you're not aware in
the comics Madame web which of course
the movie is about it's called Madam
Webb she can travel the Multiverse and
it looks like they might be leading up
to that in the SSU as well they're
hinting at it at least with Cassandra
being able to look into the future and
when she looks into the future she sees
the woman become Spiderwoman and Spider
Girl and it also talks about how her web
kind of connects everything so I think
this is where everything is going to
start to kind of get clear Sony is going
to build up to this huge spidergeddon
event to where all these Spider-Man
characters and iterations are going to
come together to eventually fight a
pretty big villain or multiple villains
an event where we'll have Tom Holland
Spider-Man Tom Hardy's Venom Toby
Maguire Spider-Man Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man a bunch of different
spiderwomen a bunch of different spider
girls other spider-men who aren't Peter
Parker silk Cindy Moon all of these
characters that we know from the comics
coming together in one Universe to take
on a villain I personally would love to
see this I would love to see liveaction
spider Gwyn with Peter Parker and silk
and Spiderwoman I would love to see all
of this and the great news is it sounds
like this is Sony's plan but let us know
what you think about this in the
comments down below how excited would
you be to see this happen on the big
screen leave a comment down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest mcus and Spider-Man in the Sony
spiderverse news as well you can find us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof